[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings the three
men convicted of killing 25 year old mod
arberry we'll learn what their sentences
are later today and whether they will
eventually have a chance of parole
travis mcmichael his father gregory
mcmichael and their neighbor that's
william roddy bryan were all found
guilty in november of felony murder
among other charges they face a
mandatory life sentence
this case gained national attention as
you know after video showed the three
men chasing arberry down and shooting
him in a georgia neighborhood it's been
nearly two years now
arberry's mother wanda cooper jones and
the arberry family attorney lee merritt
who we should point out is also running
for office in texas they are both
joining us this morning good morning to
you both and thank you so much wanda
cooper jones i would imagine this is a
very difficult day and for those of us
who are following the story we're
waiting to see how it's all going to
turn out you know at the funeral you
said
you you will get justice for your son
you promised that at the funeral
today is that day what what does justice
look like for you in terms of sentencing
and justice looks like having all three
men that are responsible for the murder
of ahmad going to jail
for the rest of their lives
with with no parole
with no parole yes ma'am that is correct
lee we understand you know that there
this is only phase one of the sentence
today you know we also have the the
federal charges on the hate crime
outstanding that is supposed to be
sentencing for that next week that trial
is supposed to happen what can you tell
us about that
well earlier this week the department of
justice approached ms wanda cooper jones
about a plea deal being offered to the
mcmichaels to spend 30 years in prison
if they admit
that what they did was motivated by hate
and we considered that offer but after
um much consideration prayer uh the
family decided to reject that offer they
wanted those men to stand trial in court
uh for the federal hate crime charges as
well that begins february 4th
uh miss cooper jones why did you reject
that is is there a part of you
that wants to hear them say that yes
we admit to guilt in the hate crime
would that have been satisfying for you
i think that the federal charges are
just as important as the state charges
and i think that they need to stand
trial for those charges as well
what does it say to you lee that they
wanted a plea deal in this case
well i think they were shocked by the
outcome in this case as much of the
nation was uh and and now they're going
to have to stand trial before some of
the best attorneys in the country out of
the department of justice uh and they're
they're going to have to admit to the
hateful nature of what they did i think
they wanted to avoid that and i think
wanda made the right decision the the
mod arberry family made the right
decision in rejecting that deal and
allowing their fate to be decided by a
federal court
wanda last time you were with us gail
asked you what do you want everyone to
know about your son and you responded by
saying
i want everyone to know that he was
loved
how did you feel how do you feel knowing
that
not only the city or the state the
nation but the world
showed you and your son love
after everything that happened
my feeling it remains the same a modest
love the love that has been shown as has
been very much appreciated
the overpower of love is why i'm still
standing today i would i'm standing here
today is because of the love
thank you all
lee what does it say to you that the the
mcmichaels wanted to plead guilty i'm
fascinated by that you know derek
chauvin also pleaded guilty in his case
when it came to the hate crimes what do
you think is happening here
i think it shows that we have a
department of justice that is
aggressively pursuing uh hate crimes
that is aggressively
pursuing accountability in in cases
where you know we haven't seen that
before and so i think they were
intimidated by the amount of preparation
and the overwhelming amount of evidence
that was going against them and they
knew that you know this wasn't going to
be another uh uh
normal day in court for them but that
they would be facing severe penalties
and so i i think the fact that they're
now asking for a plea deal just shows
the overwhelming strength of wanda
cooper jones and the community that's
organized around her and the government
government officials who have finally
come to her aid
and wanda cooper jones i'd like to know
how you're getting through you know nate
touched on it when we talked about ahmad
r barry but we were just talking at the
table before we went on the air every
time i see the video of your son jogging
knowing how the outcome is going to be
i'm wondering how you how you're getting
through and how you're processing all of
this and how you're feeling
um today is a good day um
i pray for this day and this day is yeah
it's today is a it's a it's a
bittersweet day um the day that i prayed
for it has finally come
so i'm very grateful all right
all right wanda cooper jones we thank
you for your time lee merritt thank you
good to see you too thank you both thank
you and he is gone thank you gail thank
you everyone take care thank you